issues like gay marriage or
groundbreaking issues and traditionally
they have begun in the States I'm very
proud of what the state of California is
doing has done in this regard but it is
clear that again this is a
state-by-state issue I have confidence
in the next generation are people people
who are the age of my children are
younger because they don't carry a lot
of the prejudices that older generations
may still have about this issue I know
young people think that there's no place
for discrimination in our society I
agree with that and that's why I'm
pleased with what happened in California
and I'm hopeful that we can hold off any
initiatives to change that in the
November election
you